alors deux choses verbaliser les chiens
sans laisse évidemment pardon on sait
jamais comment un chien va réagir on
sait jamais si un chien ça reste un
animal un animal c'est pas un être
humain et il peut mordre il peut donc il
doit être tenu en laisse un être humain
aussi et puis il faut être mal dressé on
en a vu plein de fois j'ai un autre
petit débat merde très rapide je l'ai
sur celui-là après mais c'est
intelligent moi mon époque ça va toi
mais comme je suis pas beaucoup là du
coup je mets tous mes débats de la
semaine auquel j'irai d'accord à mon
époque on apprenait au chien à faire
leurs besoins dans le caniveau et je
peux te dire que les nôtres ils étaient
dressés maintenant je trouve que prendre
ce petit truc en plastique et elle est
ramassée c'est dégradant pour l'homme
c'est normal
dans la rue prenez un truc et hop je te
ramasse une merde
vous avez un chien
[Rires]
je fais comme tout le monde j'ai une
moto cross derrière moi
tous les gens me voilà je suis d'accord
avec pas mal donne un mot tu es pas con
merci merci moi aussi je veux un chien
je vais l'éduquer pour que ce soit dans
quel niveau
chatte avec ma chatte
de l'acheter une lettre on m'a dit que
ça se promène pas du tout
un petit peu renseigner sur les chats
parce que
j'ai jamais vu des chats en laisse je
vais
je connais pas du tout mais c'est pas
des amis ils sont pas dans les animaux
regarde les animaux avec les animaux
de la 8 belle chatte comment les bébés
chatte je ne sais pas tu demandes belle
chatte
moi je suis choqué c'est du racisme
antichen
édictées par les gens qui n'aiment pas
les chiens
mais c'est la vérité je suis désolé les
gens qui sont pas cons regardez c'est
qu'il est pas méchant c'est qu'il s'est
passé
donc voilà les gens qui promènent les
chiens avec laisse qu'il le fassent les
gens qui promènent les chiens sans
laisse les slips c'est devenu une Tanner
d'avoir un chien on peut laisser nulle
part
n'appartient pas simplement propriétaire
de chien moi j'ai un chien que j'aime
plus que tout au monde mais je je
comment
je le promène avec une laisse parce que
de toute façon il y a aussi des gens qui
ont peur tu as des gens qui ont peur des
chiens tu as des enfants qui peuvent se
comporter tu ne sais pas ils ne savent
pas ils ont peut-être pas été habitués à
être avec des chiens
etc donc c'est tellement bête
et parce que tout le monde reste pas son
chien toi
quand j'étais petit je me suis fait
mordre par un chien
il m'a mordu aux fesses et
du coup du coup il y a des amis de la
famille de façon venue et c'était dans
un club de tennis et voilà il y a une
embrouille de ouf et tout ah tu as une
cicatrice sur la face non
[Rires]
bien sûr on rigole
évidemment qui sont très dangereux
Guillaume je suis propriétaire de chien
et je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on ait
permis d'un chien et je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on ait des permis mais moi
c'est pareil pour les Scorpions
c'est insupportable tu vois des
Scorpions se balader tranquille c'est
horrible oui Verdun franchement La
Rochelle a tout fait pour les chiens il
y a un peu tout fait pour les chiens des
sacs pour ramasser les déjections il y a
tout et ils ne font rien les
propriétaires il les laisse en liberté
tout ils sont qui ont tenaient vos
chiens donner votre nom soit je vais
dire la vérité et je te le dis c'est
pourquoi je viens jamais chez toi c'est
horrible chez toi c'est dégueulasse tu
me dégoûtes
mais arrête un peu tu dégoûtes tout le
monde et tu veux que je te dise la
vérité je vais dire un truc que je t'ai
jamais dit t'as pas remarqué que
personne ne jamais chez toi bien sûr
même l'été
ils veulent repartir ils veulent revenir
chez moi écoutez moi je vous raconte un
truc il y a des gens qui sont venus chez
moi et Guillaume chantant avait loué une
maison à côté non ils sont allés dormir
chez Guillaume chantant ils sont venus
le lendemain ils m'ont dit frère on peut
pas c'est trop sale c'est insupportable
je te jure il chie dans la piscine
non attends alors je leur ai dit c'est
peut-être Guillaume ah mais attendez non
mais non mais non mais arrête je te le
jure que c'est vrai personne personne
et oui personne ne veut dire chez toi
personne ne veut venir chez toi c'est
dégueulasse Castaldi c'est vrai ou pas
ça peut aider la même info il a souhaité
une semaine
vite vite c'est pareil pour la chaîne et
tout personne va aller chez toi tu es
dégueulasse tu dégoûtes tout le monde tu
es sale une semaine chez moi et ça
tu peux tu dégoûtes tout le monde ce qui
est vrai c'est qu'on m'avait dit que tu
avais fait le tournage
qui avait fait 100000 euh le chien des
stars ou je sais pas quoi que ce qui
avait tourné chez toi mon effectivement
il y a un peu de merde de chien et tout
c'est moi j'adore les chiens je vis avec
mes chiens et je les laisse vivre
[Rires]
et en fait je le tenais pas en laisse
parce qu'il est très bien sauf que une
fois il est venu passer un vélo c'était
il y a 2 jours il a voulu attraper le
vélo j'ai fait tomber le vélo à cause de
mon chien donc pour ces raisons là faut
parler des Ventures c'est très dangereux
il faut faire attention
j'étais très emmerdé franchement Patrick
Jean-Mi alors déjà c'est pas dégradant
ah bah c'est des crottes de son chéri
pour que les autres habitants acceptent
les chiens dans la dégradants et il doit
dresser
en caniveau si de les années 70 parce
que maintenant les eaux usées partent
sont retraités si tu veux boire de la
merde c'est ton problème mais
Jean-Michel ça change rien tu bois de la
merde de toute façon et encore une fois
je te le dis c'est pas de moi surtout
des grands auteurs mais je parle
beaucoup avec eux on dresse un chien
Mabrouki junior non mais non mais
arrêter de tout mettre au même niveau et
c'est l'erreur aussi de Guillaume les
chiens sont des êtres maintenant qu'on
respecte comme des êtres humains mais un
chien n'est pas un être humain nous on
ne chie pas dans quelques mois mais à
Paris
ça m'arrive parce que sinon on fait ça
chier dans la rue et puis on ramasse
derrière mais je le sais je le sais et
non mais La Rochelle c'est peut-être une
ville qui aime les chiens mais Paris une
n'aime pas ses chiens elle aime
plus les rats que les chiens à Paris il
y a des parcs il y a pratiquement plus
aucun impacts avec son chien parce que
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'ils font parce
que les parcs tu peux avec ton chien ou
en laisse et dès qu'il y a un jouet dès
que la manège
évite les mots de plus de trois syllabes
comme ça jouer on peut pas dire manège
pour enfants et bah du coup les chats
sont interdits donc qu'est-ce qu'ils
font il y a deux parcs à côté de chez
moi ils ont mis deux balles en soir de
merde et du coup les chiens sont
interdits de de d'aller dans le parc et
dans tous les parcs c'est comme ça à
Paris donc bravo La Rochelle et Paris
[Applaudissements]
désolé les mecs ils vont loin il va loin
et même dans les bois les bois il va
tous les soirs votre boulot
mais moi j'aime bien la balade dans le
jardin en bas de chez moi je lui mets
pas de l'Est mais je sais qu'elle est
pas dangereuse en revanche je pense
qu'il devrait peut-être y avoir juste
des règles pour que on puisse modifier
cette règle et que ce soit pour les
chiens qui soient dangereux des races
dangereux
ma chérie
excuse-moi dans tous les arrondissement
hier soir il y avait le chien de
Guillaume j'entends un des trois chiens
de Guillaume
terrorisé on a carrément changé de
couleur alors pourquoi la limite
elle a déjà mordu elle a déjà mangé
une autre chaîne que j'ai aimé voilà
alors
on peut comprendre que la chaîne a été
un peu c'est insupportable vous voyez
vous voyez mais quand une chienne
rencontre une grosse chatte
elle a eu peur de la pub bah oui non
mais quand je dis raciste mon petit
chien c'est pas exagéré c'est vraiment
des gens qui sont méprisants qui sont
détestables envers les chiens c'est le
regard genre les casser
vous voulez des chiottes quand tu étais
petit à petit
voilà qui est mordu et non elle est plus
non c'est un des problèmes qui arrivent
dans la piscine mais Cyril on a tout
résumé en une fois un jour il a dit si
je ne connais pas un bébé je connais un
chien je sauve mon chien
et ben tu le redis je le redis et ben ça
veut dire qu'en plus tu ne raisonne pas
arrêté de croire les choses c'est des
objets vous voulez des chiens toi tu
prends une chatte pour faire deux photos
sur Instagram quand il faut s'en occuper
il y a plus personne
[Musique]
mais quand on parle de transgenre et des
machins il y a rien qui choque toi les
animaux c'est plus important c'est un
nom ça méfie-toi tu sais que les plus
grand dictateurs étaient fous des
animaux bravo je te le dis ouais les
chiens Mobutu tout tout ça attention hé
c'est bon il a pris une chatte non ce
qu'il en avait jamais vu avant
tout simplement
[Musique]
quand tu donnes plus d'importance à un
animal qu'un chien qu'un être humain
c'est un nom Daniel Daniel Moreau
animal il pleurait mais bizarre là tu
parles dans des délire
monsieur en France il y a pas trompé
quand il dit je sauve un chien plutôt
qu'un bébé
c'est pas grave Mathieu c'est pas parce
que je peux te dire un truc hier tu
sauvais ta chienne ou Daniel
voilà bien sûr
non mais on savait quoi entre Daniel et
ta chaîne
Youtube
si je m'occupe de mes chers
tu chauffes ton chien pas Daniel fait
par exemple
Daniel je connais mieux ma chaîne que
Daniel donc je souffre mais voilà
moi je te jure moi je te sauve
alors attends attends
[Applaudissements]
j'aime tellement ma chienne alors j'aime
beaucoup Daniel mais entre ma chienne et
Daniel j'ai une minute pour sauver une
des deux exemples on est tous d'accord
je prends celle qui est la plus
transportable facilement
je te le dis voilà